of the NHL schedule this one tonight Crosby with
it he'll have it lifted away and AO is going to
be sprung by terab AO in on Jerry and oh what
a safe jar highlight reel needed to stop that
one less than 20 seconds in from aaho terrain just
leads him and he makes a concerted decision before
the hash marks Crosby turns it over he makes
a quick decision I'm shooting this Puck at top
speed controlling the puck along the boards he
is bothered there by the oliv Joseph NE L out FR
another highlight re save the great saves that
Gibson made early in the hockey game Thursday
night I mean a heck of a job finding a pinching
defens by trying to drop that back Carter has
a shoulder for Lemieux but the GS forward still
playing the puck forward now turned over to birds
he shot saved by jar and over the top of Ron is
net by Ricard Rael just enough pressure on Ricard
Raquel you cannot take a breath on Crosby now
here comes gel trying to drop it he'll get the
shot off on a sneaky forehand and another save
made by R as the penguins have now had a couple
of opportunities in the game zone now AO trying
to get this in deep a little help to fetch nof
along the boards better look at it and he'll
come out with AO he'll feather it across shy
score bre pesi this time jar can't stop it
and Carolina jumps out to the one- nothing
lead short order your defense involved peshi in
particular this Puck is going to hit something on
the way in it definitely hit a Pittsburgh body
I believe you win a board battle AO did yes it
hits the glove of larsell winning the trenches
AO and Company and own a little deeper along the
boards it goes jar trying to help it around he'll
step it from stall the chapi it now deflected up
front Martin Waits his shot right up they score
Jordan martinook it's a two nothing Carolina
lead ends up holding on to this Puck for
a precious extra second tough interchange
between jari and ruido because of the pressure
of all that puck hits a Pittsburgh skate and
Martin great here holds on to it for an extra
second maybe since the jari had gone out with
his stick with one hand and so the lower portion
would be available kanes have the legs early in
this one 95 left in the first and now Carolina
forcing another turnover all out in front and
another save by jar B itself free Carolina will
see Russ to carry this one in and he goes to the
backand and a little p check there when he's
been tested he's had the answers Carolina two
nothing so if we don't see him I'm sure we
will but big congratulations Kane's working
out in front and jar again this time robbing
terrain three four outstanding saves I mean
it's been just a press of all presses from
Carolina the Penguins will still hang on to
the plot Crosby we get this one back long drive
deflected Ro out in front and he'll get a piece
of that try as gensel chopped going to the
front before the whistle this is a a great
save gensel has had at least two good chances
and now R is trying to get his bearings at the
other end is Carolina works it out in front and
an opportunity for Fetch nikov and then fetch
nikov helps it along for burns back for Jarvis
back to Burns Jarvis again and he CLS that one
off the metal gains have a two nothing lead and
Seth Jarvis loaded this one up great stick by P
to he leaves it off the boards and Jarvis he's
got stole with him sto shot right on Save made
by jar tries to go low off the backwards gensel
will get to it now up top Carlson takes the shot
reload second shot saon a rebound there and
somehow that stays up rer keeping it up and
then there's a dog pile on the K's net minder
okay let's admire the save first and foremost on
gensel and there is a I mean there is a
push from Jordan Stall that's the central
piece of gel lightning you know what
though how the heck is Ricard Raquel
on his own bition well inside the paint
he he can't be he he did not get put let
will you'll really be able to tell
from the overhead rael's outside of
it now he's inside RTO makes a great
save now Eller with a second chance he'll
PA down he'll work this one for it now
a chance Po in drive and save made by Russ
holding the post didn't see the rebound ell
shot doesn't get through now an opportunity
for Carolina to clear and they will as Here
Comes Co across for or and he Rings the post
and that deflects out of play keep an eye on
him cross quter shot hammer it on there save
his M out of the net oh mercy R what a save
2024 oh baby father Finn with the leather
on one of the alltime greats two nothing
Carolina just took his lunch mark money on
that save Crosby looking for more GES will
knock it away pesi will flip it up GES can't
clear Crosby keeps it in Cross I for gel the
score and the pens get on the board with 135
left here in the third period be after that
save of the Year candidate to worry about the
next sh Carolina thought they were advancing
out of their end with the puck Pittsburgh turns
it over over and Crosby's chemistry with Jake
gensel he knows where he's going to bee east west
across the ice with Pace now knocked out vov he'll
knock it to Shay Shay splits the middle and he
shot right on and the save made by jar wah just
delivered right there winning the draw from Crosby
that'll be knocked down by Tera Ling but the pass
goes off of the skate of fetch to kicked by py
and R KES it out Carlson former shark teammate
with it he'll drift along the boards he back
set up for L the last minute here in the third
period 2-1 lead for Carolina now long drive
save rebound out a rust and he scores R makes
the initial save kicked out to Brian rust and
he ties this one at two with 52.7 left when the
stall line was trying to Salt it on the floor
check you come out of your own end clean with
speed jar goes to the bench I mentioned leang
he makes another good play puts it right in the
Wheelhouse for Carlson Carlson fires away you've
got a net front you utilize the extra attacker
on the ice and that's a pretty darn impressive
finish that puck from a pretty severe angle on
edge Jarvis taking a look he finds
pesi tavina the other forward for
Carolina Crosby washing pesy tavina
didn't like what he saw so he'll turn
it away Crosby wants a change ter tries to
take advantage he'll drop it back py shot he
scores two for 22 tonight and Carolina wins
it 32 and overtime Burns fought for possession
and once you get possession be with it and
that's exactly what Terra vinan was at one
point he had turned up just as outside the
Pittsburgh Blue Line eventually gets Brett
pesy who will probably be the first star
of the night I don't know how he can't be